As John said,
the United
States of America
versus Donald Trump and wall
not a who is his valet.
Paula, first to you.
You've been going through
what stands out.
The first thing that stands out
is, let's recall our town hall
where our colleague Kaitlan Collins asked
former President Trump fired over,
showed anyone classified information.
His response was not really
what this indictment suggests.
That quote, on two occasions in 2021
the former president showed
classified documents to others.
Now, this indictment specifically lists
two instances.
The first is in July 2021
at his Bedminster Golf Club.
This is the audio recording.
We broke this news last week.
Today, we exclusively brought people
the exact transcript
which is reflected here.
They describe how he tried to show
a document to members of his staff,
people who were there writing a book,
none of whom, quote, possessed
a security clearance.
He described it as a plan of attack,
basically confirming our reporting.
The second incident is in August
or September of 20, 21,
they say also at Bedminster,
the former president showed
a representative
of his political action
committee, a PAC,
who also did
not have a security clearance,
a classified map
related to a military operation,
and told that person
he should not be showing it to them
and that their representative
should not get too close.
So just in the first couple of pages,
we have two instances of the former
president months
after he left the White House.
Sharing classified.
Other thing that stands out to me
as I look at
what I believe is the first addendum
counts one to 31.
There are 31 counts
and 30 listed one by one.
And as often happens
if you look for instance
at the Manhattan case
counts under the same category.
Right. So so. Right.
So tell us what stands out to you.
I think they're specific crimes
and I think
one of the big items
here is the fact that
the former president was was
obstructing this investigation.
And what this indictment does
is it goes through some of the instances
that what they say
they accused the former
president of doing.
They say that he falsely
he had his
he told his lawyer to falsely
tell the FBI
and the grand jury
that he did not
have these documents
that were being called for by that
he was demanded to produce
instructed his attorney to correct right.
And it doesn't say exactly,
at least from what I'm reading,
which one.
But we know that Evan
Corcoran is one of his attorneys
who did
testify and who was forced to testify
and who whose attorney client work
was produced
to prosecutors
as a result of a court order.
Does this presume that Corcoran told
federal prosecutors
that he was told to lie? Again, we don't.
From what
we're reading right now,
we're still going through it.
It doesn't exactly lay this out,
but it lists
the various obstruction items
that the former president
is being accused of.
It also says
that the former president directed
the the defendant, Walton Order
to move boxes of documents
to conceal them from his attorney.
Again, that's
we know that Evan Corcoran is the person
who was going to do a search
to try to satisfy this subpoena
that he was under,
that the former president
was under to produce these documents.
This happened last summer.
Again,
according to
the federal prosecution here,
is that what Nada was being told
to move
documents, these boxes of documents
to conceal them from Evan Corcoran
ahead of time
before he conducted this search?
Yes, and also, we're now able to report
that here at three P. M.
So here in just about an hour or so,
the special counsel
is going to be making a statement.
So this is very unusual.
You do not often see this. Right.
And so what should we be
looking for here?
What do you think, Evan,
that this is going to be like?
Look,
I think the importance of Jack Smith
and I know the
you know, the Justice Department
and the way that the system
operates right
now, they're trying to restore
normalcy to the department
after the last few tumultuous years.
And there is a lot reluctance
for them to speak anything or see
anything outside of these
court documents.
But the importance of Jack
Smith coming out today
is that you need to have someone
who can explain to the American public,
this is what we've done.
This is what this investigation has done.
According to this this document the
the Federal Bureau of Investigation
opened a criminal investigation
of the former
president on March 30th of 2022.
So this investigation has been going on
since March 30th of last year.
And, you know, it's important
for Jack Smith,
who has run this investigation
since he became special counsel
for the
for someone to stand
before the cameras
and the American public
and explain
what it is
that this investigation has done.
Why it's important to do these things,
why it's important
to bring these charges.
I should note,
it's actually not just 31 counts.
It's one to 31 for willful
retention
of national defense information.
But it goes on to list additional counts
conspiracy to obstruct justice.
32 count 33
withholding a document or record count
30 for corruptly concealing a document
or refered.
And by the way, each of those listing
Donald Trump
either by himself
or along with
not a count
35 concealing a document
in a federal investigation
count 36 scheme to conceal count 37
false statements and representations
count 38 each to a long list.
Each document is a crown each
and we now know what documents
we're talking about for all this time
we haven't known all the documents.
38 counts at all. 38 is the count.
They listed 31 documents as well.
I just had a jaw dropper here,
and I've been covering this
along with Evan for nearly a year now.
On page ten,
they describe how Walt Norton was
one of the people who helped him
pack up his boxes.
The boxes went from the White House.
They contain classified information
to the Mar-A-Lago Club,
but they say from January
through March, 15, 20, 21,
some of those boxes were stored
in the Mar
a Lago Club's White and gold ballroom.
They have a picture of it.
This so class boxes
with classified documents
in a ballroom
where they, quote,
had events and gatherings taking place.
They were for a time
stacked on the ballroom stage
as depicted in this photograph.
And they obscure the person's identity.
They appear to have taken a picture
with these boxes.
I mean, that is a stunning detail
that our classified secrets
were in a ballroom in southern Florida.
And here's why that's even
just think about the attack context
that we talk about the Espionage Act
and why this is so important
Normally, people think about espionage,
think about the traditional
spying apparatuses,
but the Espionage Act
is to guard
against the disclosure
or the careless retention of documents
by those who are not authorized
to have them,
who do not have the lawful
custodial responsibility of those.
It includes
people who otherwise would have
had the authority
to have the documents
and have placed them in a position,
as Paula is alluding to,
where it could be viewed or disclosed
and may have listed
for the first time
now the 31 documents
of different levels of top
security clearance,
top secret clearance
at different points to suggest
that the issue of
whether or not
this will fall
into the category of defense
related information.
This has now been clearly identified.
Let's just to note that
I've covered the intelligence agencies.
I had a security clearance myself
for a couple of years.
I'm going to read
some descriptions of the documents
involved here.
Number four, top secret special handling,
including military activities
and planning of foreign countries.
Number five, document dated
June 2020 concerning nuclear
capabilities of a foreign country.
Number nine,
undated document concerning
military attacks by a foreign country,
some of them
not just the top secret label,
but the no foreign label
that stands for no foreign meaning.
These
these documents were not
meant to be shared with anybody
outside the U.S.
intelligence community due
to their sensitivity.
In other words,
these are not know low level
classification markings.
And, by the way, not low level topics.
For classical,
classical, classified
intelligence markings,
nuclear
foreign attacks, military activities
by foreign countries.
It's sensitive,
sensitive material
Yeah, it's in
this indictment is really fascinating.
I will say, as you read part of it
and you can see
they're looking at the deposition of Walt
not or his testimony and underscoring
what they say
they know to be false about the movement
of some of these documents.
There's a lot that this reveals.
There's a lot that it also does
not reveal. To your point, Laura Coates.